so thank you very very much for for the
platform i really appreciate it um
second of all just my experience was i
was a mischievous kid at school very uh
very agitated was one of those class
clowns and uh yeah got myself in you
know a little bit of trouble and got
expelled at the age of 15 for nothing
other than just being a class clown
um
i just you know with the the current
curriculum that we're currently sitting
in i think
with the with the survey that we've done
we feel that there's a lot more that can
be done in the in the uk especially when
you look at what's happening in wales
where they have mandated it and it works
so that's just the same reason really
i've looked at that and started asking
the question why we're not doing that in
england
and now obviously as you were just
saying that the current system you're
saying is failing children from ethnic
minorities and you have children of your
own who are growing up at a time when
the message of black lives matter is
prevalent so how does their experience
compare or differ to yours and indeed do
you think things have changed
yes i believe that um
when we we try and put like black lives
matter i feel like that's where you know
government have said they don't want to
politicize anything but if we if we
remove away from that when you look at
other sectors of of the curriculum so
i t for example when i was a young man
was word art learning how to do some
graphs
my son now is 12 years old and he can
correctly code he can get trains to stop
and keep things moving so when you look
at how that's moved forward and how
that's shaped in a 15 year spell i think
we can ask the same question when you're
talking about history
now
as a black person the time that i get a
lot of accusations of division thrown at
me is often when i talk about black
lives matter for some reason
particularly on social media it really
just winds people up and some argue that
it's divisive because all lives matter
and quite frankly i'm exhausted trying
to explain that distinction but from
your experience and on this journey that
you're on trying to get the curriculum
to really make some major changes what
have you experienced
yeah very much the same um
i think it's a very interesting thing
when people could say that it's divisive
when if you just look at you know kobe
for example vaccines and anti-vaccines
but was was divisive if
uh the message that came out from the
education minister
not too long ago i think it was last
week that was very divisive as well
we're not allowed to talk on palestine
and things of that nature so i don't
think there's anything that you can
really say nowadays that is or isn't
divisive um
what i'm more in the business of is
solutions
if the solution's there why don't we try
and do that why do we have a
conversation
the more information everybody has we
will be in a better place moving forward
that's just my belief
yes i mean you mentioned the um the
guidance that the education secretary um
published the department for education
and actually went on to say that where
schools wish to teach about specific
campaigning organizations such as some
of those associated with the black lives
matter moment they should be aware that
this may cover partisan political views
so with this approach then from the
department for education singling out of
course the black lives matter movement
and of course with the aim that you have
how can we get to a solution as you
mentioned there how can we get to a
stage where the government and indeed
teachers feel comfortable and empowered
to talk about topics that can be you
know tricky and difficult to talk about
such as racism such as colonialism
um so what we've done within this survey
is we reached out i said just over a
thousand teachers uh responded and and
they did it and uh the numbers were
quite staggering to be totally honest
with it it was
it's worrying that only 12 percent feel
that they have been empowered that's
something that we need to talk about
again um thankfully when this open
letter came out the education minister
reached out to us and said he wants to
have that conversation so that puts us
in a real great position where we can
actually have that dialogue but the
biggest thing for me as i said earlier
with solutions is i've been to schools
where it's been enacted and enabled on
it doesn't cost anything else it's
already in the budget because i did ask
these schools are you having to find
additional money they said no it's
already in there
that was one thing but the biggest thing
is there is groups out there now
actively teaching uh teachers the
dialogue the right way to deliver uh
because as we know it's a really uh
difficult and tough subject so um we
want to be able to to speak
but also give teachers that
self-assurance that what you're speaking
will not get you sucked you know if you
say something wrong and admit to that
you know with the intention of doing
something right you won't get sacked you
won't be
out of the role because i think that is
where a lot of the problems come now
people are very worried about what they
say and how they say it so they're just
saying nothing can we ignore the uh the
situation
now the welsh government of course has
taken the lead here what's the noises
that you're hearing when you're speaking
to
the government here in england
um as i say we already reached out last
night and and within an hour we got a
response which was something that uh
caught us off quite hard if we're being
totally honest we anticipated that being
having to get a more
social and as much presence as possible
to generate that noise for to hear back
so what we're hearing now is that there
is um actually
some evidence that they want to reach
out they want to
listen and see what the solutions are so
it's on us now to get everybody behind
it with the help of yourselves giving me
a platform to talk where we can we've
created a hashtag this allows people to
talk about their experiences of school
and we're hoping to do something
similarly to the metoo movement where
people can have their experiences on
there and we can talk and create a
conversation that we can then put to
government as well that it's not just
troy and this survey it's lots and lots
of people's uh opinions
their their school in education and
their feelings and we can talk and
hopefully get to a positive uh solution
for this
absolutely and try hopefully you can
keep us up to date with um how you get
on thank you very much indeed troy
deeney there speaking to us